Wait, where am I?
Why am I not on the screen?
Oh, there I am!
What a way to start.
Where am I?
I feel like a fucking lost grandparent.
Being like, kids, where is Grand Doki?
Oh my god, let me turn down.
Great news.
I'm turning down Void.
I'm turning down the voices for the next game.
Oh my god, the golden kappa train?
Wait, isn't that rare?
Guys, we hit the rare golden kappa!
Night train!
That's rare, right?
Oh my god, we've been blessed.
We've been blessed today for day four of the Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
They have blessed us.
Also, Sound Guide, if you're here, I'm gonna need you to let me know if the sound's gonna be, like, messed up or not.
Guys, okay, here's some updates.
Oh my god, thank you!
Oh my god!
That's so many!
Oh!
So many subs!
Thank you, everybody!
PTD, thank you for the five gifted subs!
Oh, it's so many!
It's golden kappa!
It's your time to get a golden kappa!
Thank you for the biddies, Meki!
Okay, after I get eliminated, I'll thank everybody.
I'll pull up the list.
I don't have the list.
It's not a hit list.
It's, like, the list of people who gifted and, like, subbed and all that stuff.
I don't have it up right now.
But after we get eliminated in, like, the doll game, I'll pull it up, because it's going so fast.
Next thing, thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
And Karin, thank you for the 200 biddies!
Alright, guys.
This is crazy.
This is actually crazy.
But after the stream ended, and for three... I think for, like, four hours, they kept arguing.
It was...
I think for, like, four to five hours after we thought it was over, people reignited the argument in the Discord chat.
Like, they... It was actually insane.
Because, like, you know what happened?
One of the admins posted an update.
And then it reignited the conversation.
And then they started pulling up, like, actually rules and stuff.
They're like, you said in this rule that players who don't... who choose to not... who choose... don't follow the rules because they were ignorant doesn't count.
And then they pulled that rule... Wait, let me get... pull it up.
Because it was so funny.
Oh my...
I read that, and it was so funny.
I was like, oh my god!
Okay, let me... I need to see this again.
Because it was... it was actually... I... I was like, what the heck?
Like...
Okay, being... This is a real rule, by the way.
Being unaware of the rules does not exempt participants from elimination.
Organizers reserve the right to enforce rules and take necessary actions.
So that is like a legit rule in the server for the game.
So then somebody took that and was like, why does this not apply now?
So people... and then everyone was like, wait, you're right!
So people took that rule to, like, use it against the admins.
Because they're like, you wrote this rule!
So those players who were unaware of those rules should not...
should not exempt participants.
I was just like, why are we drag... Bro!
Bro, it's day five!
Day four now!
Why are we dragging this back up?
I thought we all agreed!
I thought all of us agreed on it!
What do you mean?
The arguments ended at, like, um, 8pm.
Everybody stopped arguing at 8pm.
Because the admins dropped the rules for, uh, they dropped the rules for, like, um, game... what was it?
Game six and seven?
Okay, wait, is it six and seven?
Yeah, yeah, they dropped the rules for game six.
Oh my gosh!
There's a specific... I don't even know if we're gonna make it to the second game today.
Because the first game today is, um, the first game is going to be the doll game.
Our favorite game, by the way.
It's gonna be the doll game.
Um, there's gonna be no time limit, and it only stops each round, um, after six players are eliminated.
So, like, yeah, each doll... the doll has to eliminate six players, and there's no time limit until six players are dead.
And then we go to the second round.
Until 30 players are eliminated in the end.
So we're going until 30 players are eliminated, so that we have 40 players left in the game.
Yeah, so, like, each doll... each round has at least six eliminations.
So, um, or at most six eliminations.
So, like, that's how they're gonna...
They removed the safe dolls!
Yay!
Finally, they removed the safe dolls.
Because there was no point.
Apparently the safe dolls was, like, it was bad to hit the safe dolls.
Then why the heck were they called safe?
If it was so bad, why did you name the safe dolls safe?
Because the safe dolls actually made the cursed dolls faster.
So when you hit the safe dolls, you're just making the cursed dolls move faster.
So I was like, wait, then it shouldn't be called safe.
Like, what?
That, like, messed me up.
That, like, actually messed me up.
I was like, wait, what's the point then?
Why did they call it safe?
Okay, let's, like, mute.
I don't want to listen to the voices today.
For now.
We'll listen to the voices when we have to run.
So they removed it.
Oh my god.
Golden Kappa level 12!
Thank you for the level 12 Kappa Twain!
Okay, I, like, wrote down everything I wanted to say today about the updates.
Alright.
Okay.
And then, after they dropped the new rules, after they dropped the new rules, all the pro Minecraft players started theorycrafting and talking about, like, infinite sprint jobs.
And then I'm like, what the heck is infinity?
They're like, can we do infinity sprint jump?
And I'm like, what the what words are they speaking?
Excuse me.
And then, cause the second game, like, there's no point in explaining the second game, because I don't even know about Bro, the dolls are gonna kill six people, like, for a round.
Like, 30 people are gonna get eliminated.
So, um, all I'm saying is, like, there's no point in me explaining the second game when there's a, like, I feel like, the moment I'm eliminated, everybody's just gonna be like, oh, hey, and then turn off.
So, true.
True.
And so, um, um, so I'm not gonna explain the second game until until, like, if I survive the second game, I'll explain it.
But, the second game, all I'm saying, when they the second game, so, like, we have, like, a daily itinerary, and like, they post a daily they post a daily itinerary for, like, every game, but it's like, it's all in one post.
But the second game had its very own channel.
Because the rules, I thought, like, the last game, the prop hunt game, had a lot of rules.
But the second game today had its own channel, and then it had its own separate FAQ channel, because everybody was asking questions, and I was just like, oh my god.
I was just reading it, and I'm like, why am I reading this?
I don't even know I'm gonna make it this far.
Why?
Why am I reading the friggin' FAQ itinerary for this?
Yeah.
So, like, so I just stopped reading, because I was like, why am I even reading this?
Like, I don't even know if I'm gonna get there.
So people were, like, asking, like, FAQ about, like, what can we do?
And what can we not do?
And stuff.
But it was just, it was so interesting.
Just, like, seeing all the Minecraft pros just, like, trying to see what they can, like, I guess, like, exploit, type deal.
And for, like, an easier game.
Like, what separates from a, um, an actual Minecraft player from a, from, you know, random VTuber number 13.
So, it was pretty funny.
I was just, like, reading it.
I'm like, what the heck?
I'm, like, reading the general chat to see all these people talking about the Minecraft tech.
And, like, talking about what they can and can't do.
And stuff like that.
And I'm just like, what's going on?
Oh my god.
No, it's, I, I, it's crazy.
I didn't realize how, how, like, how complicated Minecraft and also Minecraft drama can be.
You know, I've always read about the, like, the Minecraft stuff.
But being in the thick of it and listening to, like, the conversations, I was like, wow.
Oh my god.
At this point of stage, one of the pro players for an FPS game will start saying slurs.
But wow.
And then, and then they get dropped by their org.
This is, wow.
I'm, I don't know what's going on.
Like, what they're saying really.
But, like, wow.
Wait.
They're still arguing about yesterday?
Oh my gosh.
No.
I, like, saw some of the tweets of, like, the fans.
And, like, I was, like, I saw, I saw some of the tweets on both sides.
And from the, the things that, the trending part.
Cause I was, like, wondering, like, wait.
Are they like, against or for any of the people supporting?
I was, like, whoa.
I was, like, oh my god.
So how old are these fans again?
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't.
That was a low blow.
That was, I'm sorry, Minecraft community.
But, like, that was, that was a low blow.
I was, like, I'm just, like, how old are, how old are these children?
Like, low blow but not wrong.
No, no.
If you've seen some of the screen, like, not the screenshots, but, like, when you drag the fans into the argument and then you see the fans arguing for you on either side, you know, for either side.
I'm not saying, like, one side or the other.
Like, I'm for, for either side.
I thought it was really funny as an outsider.
As an outsider, I thought it was really funny.
.
It was actually, if you've seen the tweets, you would know what I mean.
Um, if you've seen the tweets.
But, yeah, anyway.
Yeah, that's, like, the Minecraft update for the day.
There's stuff that I wrote down.
Oh, yeah.
Also, like, they were, like, oh, my gosh.
I mean, to be fair, it is $70,000 and, like, people were like, I didn't realize people were, like, VOD reviewing.
Like, they were VOD reviewing their competition to, like, find weakness.
Like, I was like, wait, this is, like, Apex scrims or Overwatch scrims.
They were legit VOD reviewing their opponents to see, like, the text they were using.
Cause, like, you know how I'm in the ultimate hardcore The ultimate hardcore Minecraft server.
Like, um, so, like, I know, I realized they were actually, like, VOD reviewing like, their competitors to, like, see the tech and stuff and, like, see, like, you know, what they're using and, like, trying to, um, to, like, gather knowledge and, like, see the weakness and stuff like that.
What do you think, guys?
I don't even have a name to them.
Like, they don't even give me a name.
Like, what do you think?
Like...
Um, and it was I was like, oh my god.
Like, to be fair, it is 70k.
It is 70k.
It's life-changing money.
Um, so, like, to some of the people here.
So, it's like, um, and it's life-changing money to some of the people here, but it's also just, like, you know, bragging rights to some of the people here.
For some of the people, cause, like, I don't know if you guys know this, but, like, if you're a really popular Minecraft creator, you can make a lot of money.
You can essentially be a million there.
So, like, for others, it's just bragging rights.
For others.
Um...
Is drops enabled?
Can I, like, lie about Like...
Can I just be like, yes.
Toki, no.
Um...
Uh, I mean, how with the children, though?
How with the children?
I don't know.
I don't know if drops are on.
How do I set up drops?
Alright, guys, let me look at my... I still have time.
Uh...
Oh, drops!
Where's the Minecraft one?
Do I even get the Minecraft drop?
Wait, is there a Minecraft drop?
Oh, my God.
All I see is, like, was it the tank one?
Okay.
Wait, why don't I get the drop?
I'm in this event.
Wait a minute.
I don't even get this drop, but I'm in this event!
Wait, guys, I lied.
I totally...
Guys, I totally have drops, guys.
It's been four days.
I can't...
Guys!
I have drops, guys.
I have... I have...
I 100% have drops, guys.
Trust me.
Um...
Truth.
Also, like, the Spanish community saw my clip of the grave-spinning thing.
No shit!
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Look!
I...
I assumed since I played...
Look, I didn't check, but, like, since I assumed, since, like, I already...
I'm already in four days.
I was the number one Minecraft in Minecraft streamer for, like, two...
an hour straight.
Okay, guys?
So I assumed I would get drops.
And also because I made it to day four, chat.
So, like, if I don't actually have drops, that's not my fault.
That's Twitch's fault.
Bite the hand that feeds you.
I'm dragging Twitch down with me.
I...
I shouldn't have to ask for it, guys.
All I'm saying though is I shouldn't have to ask about the Twitch drop.
Anyway.
So if anybody comes in here asking about Twitch drop, just say yes.
Just say yes.
Because the blame is not on me if we don't have it.
I'm so scared.
Gosh.
I'm so anxious now.
I bought myself a cookie from Subway.
Because I...
I was so anxious from...
from this game mode.
I hate the dolls...
I hate the dolls game mode so much.
I think the dolls game mode is my most hated game mode.
Because that shit makes you even more anxious because everybody is screaming.
That's the worst part.
When everybody is screaming and you don't know what's going on.
So, like, you're, like, even more freaked out.
.
When the voices take over.
Yeah.
When the voices take over and you're just like, please.
I turned down the voice for everybody.
By a lot.
Oh yeah, I should turn up Goomy.
I need to find Goomy on here.
Because my sound guy was just like, just turn up Goomy and turn everybody down since you talk to her the most.
I was like, that's so smart.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's V.
Hannah, do you have all the eggs?
No, I only have 35.
Alright, we'll turn her up.
Alright.
Because then that makes sense though.
That actually makes sense.
I have the map of where they all are.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's the update for today.
If we live past the...
If we live past the dolls event, then like, God is real.
God is real.
And they try to play a sick joke at me.
What if you don't know?
No way!
All I'm saying is, if I live...
This is me.
Oh my God, this is me.
The last three remaining D's.
The last three D's of everywhere here.
If...
If I don't live past the dolls event, then there is a possibility.
There is a poss...
I can't just say God is not real.
Because...
I don't want to get into that right now.
There is a possibility.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I hope Gumi lives and I get eliminated, so I don't get dragged into Valorant.
Because she'll be too busy playing the next game.
That's like all I hope for.
That's all I hope for.
That's all I want.
True!
That is the key escape plan.
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi!
Bye, boy!
Uh-huh!
Bye!
I can't do that!
I can't hear a lot of things.
I'm scared!
Are you alive?
My arms are numb!
Are you not alive?
I am!
But people were like, oh, Donkey's not alive!
I got one guide!
Imagine getting one guide!
I got one guide.
I was worried for you, okay?
I got one guide, I was worried for you!
One, two, Freddy's coming for you.
I'm ready.
I hope you make it to the next round, Gumi, and then I get eliminated.
I hope I don't.
Why not?
Did you not see the next game?
It sounds so fun!
It had its own channel and everything!
Yeah!
I saw it!
Yeah, I saw it!
I also was like, wow!
I was like, wow, what happened to the RNG factors so that anybody can win?
They want VTuber out!
They want me out!
They tried to get me out!
It's so hard to get me out!
What happened to that?
I was like, looking at it, I was like, wait, I thought, I thought they would, now it's all skill!
Woah!
It's ten minutes!
Okay, here!
Ten minutes is crazy!
Oh my god, alright.
Also, yes, the next two games are all skill-based.
Heavily Minecraft skill-based.
So I was like, what happened?
What happened to the RNG?
I thought...
Woah!
What if the other people come into the corner?
Happy pride!
Oh my god, okay, let me...
I don't... other?
Wait, does that mean like...
the volume of any sound?
Oh, not listed below!
Okay.
This is bad EV, bro.
I'm not playing here.
This is the only way.
There's no all button!
That's so messed up!
Who are these people?
What do you think about...
There's no all button.
I have to manually do this myself.
I thought other was all!
But other are the things that are not in here.
Like, what is...
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Wait, I have an idea.
God, it's not players.
It's not players.
What are they?
Who are they?
Okay.
F.
I'll do all the F's.
We're all the F's.
Wait, how are they still going?
It's gonna be 60 next...
Oh, my God.
It doesn't push the ball.
Who is it?
I need to know their names.
Okay.
I see the names.
Oh!
I'm on the main screen.
Oh, well, the main screen's gonna see me be toxic right now.
This is the most interesting combination of three people to be singing three lines.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
I love that, guys.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It feels so nice.
Okay, Sage is okay.
She's okay.
I'm not unmuting that.
I don't care what they say.
I don't care what anybody says.
Sylvie's okay.
If I don't know them, I'm also...
Oh, wait.
The admins don't even talk.
Oh, I've muted some players.
By that, I mean...
Did you get out yesterday?
I did.
I got dropped four times in a row and then got counted up four rounds.
I could hear you.
You're second chance.
I care a little bit.
Okay, I dare you to reveal the players.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, I got my jersey on.
We're gonna win now.
You know how the lights turn off?
You know what I mean?
When they start?
I think the second they TP you, I think you can still move.
Oh, I tried.
I tried that yesterday.
Did it work?
It did, but I still do it nonetheless just to get a head start of everyone.
Yeah, I'm gonna try and like walk backwards.
Why did you do that Wolfie video?
Further away from the goal, you know what I mean?
Tech, guys.
Minecraft tech.
We're stealing intel.
It wasn't like a bet or something?
No, Wolfie.
Oh, literally when you just walked up to me I lowered every single person's volume.
Except the people I really know well.
That's so smart!
I don't know anybody!
comp size is still important, but not important enough for me to get ahead.
You wanna be on it?
But that's so smart!
But I don't know anybody!
Okay.
Okay, 5UP has been giving good intel.
So I'll keep 5UP up.
I don't know anybody else.
Good luck.
I hope you survive to the next round.
I love you!
Happy surprise!
You'll save me, right Gumi?
You'll make sure I won't die, right?
Anyways.
I will be on the opposite side.
Of everybody.
Wait, wait, wait!
There's more!
I will be wherever nobody is.
So we don't hear the voices.
It doesn't matter.
All I'm saying is that it doesn't matter.
We all get randomly TP'd.
We all get randomly TP'd somewhere.
So it doesn't matter.
Hello!
Come to my color!
It doesn't matter!
See?
It's green!
I told you it doesn't matter!
Here we go.
Whoa!
Here we go!
Right, right, right.
Oh, no, no, no.
It doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna follow the people in the front.
We need a better one.
We need to watch this.
This is the spot, guys!
Watch left and right.
Wait, Gumi's not in this group.
So fast, so fast.
Gumi's not in this group.
I hate you.
Gumi, she's not in this group.
What the hell is wrong with you?
We have to chill until six minutes.
Gumi, where are you?
It's okay.
I'm in the middle.
I don't help out.
I'm just a leecher.
I know my place.
Oh, they're running.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Everything's fine.
It's not fine.
I heard somebody get hit.
It's okay.
It's not fine.
I heard people get hit.
You never.
Andre.
Yo, you're tweaking.
Just die for us, please.
I love that.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
We're gonna go left.
Left, left, left.
Right, right, right, right.
We got comms.
Oh shit.
Don't stop.
Keep running.
Oh my god.
They're so pretty.
They are.
They are so pretty.
They're like this size.
They're like Zia.
Oh my god.
Gumi's better.
I love how they start.
My brother, no.
Is it only one doll?
No one behind us.
There's several.
No one behind.
No.
He didn't complain at all.
This is scary.
Okay, I'm fucking.
Oh my god.
I can't hear the sounds.
I hear so many people.
That's so scary.
Right, right, right, right.
Mine, mine, mine, mine.
Oh my god.
Oh, the fuck is he doing?
He's dragging.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I messed up.
No, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I saw.
I got confused because I thought people turned around.
Oh, people are turning around.
People are turning around.
Oh my god.
Good thing I was first.
We have one behind.
Oh my god.
Oh, the places are so strong.
No!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Just keep going.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
Five of them died.
Five of them actually died.
Oh my god.
Any spot here?
Five of them actually died.
Oh my god.
I just saw.
I saw five of them die in front of me.
He even died next to me.
Oh my god.
I made it.
I'm better than him.
I am that Vtuber.
Oh my god.
That is so scary.
I claim another soul.
I claimed another soul.
Oh my god.
If I eliminate this one, I'm fine.
I took one down.
I took a Minecraft pro in front of me.
I took a...
I'm okay with that.
I'm actually okay with that because I took a Minecraft pro player down.
That's alright.
Right.
I'm fine with that outcome.
I just thought that was funny.
We merged here.
Last merge.
Just say it.
Corner.
Merge here.
With another group.
I'm pretty sure I went after them.
They are over that way.
Okay.
I'm here.
5UP died next to me.
It was me and 5UP.
And the doll chose him.
Oh no.
I mean the people can't.
The people can't find us.
Yeah, but I don't think they are finding people.
I think they are just running.
Are the spawns like randomized?
Yeah, they are randomized now.
Your spawn points are randomized now.
I think we should go through this corner right now.
The worst part was that Yesterday, he would have made it.
If he didn't fought for our side to like have a restart of another game.
He would have actually made it to the next round.
That's like the actual That's like the most messed up part.
The most messed up part.
That was that.
He could have made it.
If he didn't fought for us.
Rest in peace, man.
Rest in peace.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I don't remember any bombs going off.
This is bomb 1.
Nobody is dying too.
The real one.
It's not the fireball one.
It's not.
The fireball one has a pompadour.
I think this is the one that's invisible.
No, no, no, no.
That is a scam.
I feel like the invisible one has to be a troll.
There's no way.
No way.
It's a doll that looks like one of us.
And it's in the group.
And it doesn't get you until the end.
Wait, no, don't say that!
Okay, just stop moving.
Don't go close.
Wally, why are you standing up right now?
I hear them.
There's no time.
That's the thing.
Let's banish Wally.
There's no time, by the way.
So, like, it only stops when six people are eliminated.
The fact that no one's died and no one's run past us probably means something.
Keep talking to me.
Wally, come on.
You went and did it to my dog, man.
Gumi's dog is worth it.
Thank you.
You love Kazu.
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
This is anxiety the game right now.
I'm standing for that one, too.
I'll get back up then, twin.
I'm so scared.
I've been in a Minecraft event for the past four days.
Happy Pride.
We're all waiting.
There's a doll that's gonna kill us.
And we have to survive and those six people are dead.
So I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
My heart is beating.
I think everyone's in each corner.
Wherever the doll...
We're all in the corner, right?
Runners, okay, okay.
We rotate slow.
Rotate slow.
Let's merge groups.
I don't wanna be, like, in the very beginning.
This guy gave wrong comps earlier.
That was the one time.
We'll be going down the wrong direction.
Run!
Save, save, save.
Save, save, save, save.
Team behind us, not safe.
Team behind us.
Oh, no!
I can't see!
I'm running.
Okay, okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, you can stop.
You can stop running.
Guys, you guys can stop.
We're fine, we're fine.
No!
If I do F5, guys, guys, if I do F5, it's worse because I'm bumped into things.
I'm directionally challenged.
They're trying to troll us.
We're not trolling.
Would I ever lie?
Wait, there's literally nothing lying.
Oh, my God.
I'm so confused!
Wait, wait, wait.
What's going on?
Yeah, just stop.
Maybe stop next corner.
This is the best corner.
Oh, my God.
This group merged.
Good job, guys.
This group got bigger.
I feel like everyone's here.
How did this group get bigger?
No, no, there's another group.
Crouch, crouch, crouch.
How did I squeeze?
How did we fucking get stipulated to have a magic group?
The group expansion.
I don't like flying.
How did this group get bigger?
You can see through the thing right there.
Just F5.
Oh, my God.
I don't understand.
There's more of us now.
I'm going to believe in the group.
Yeah, how is no one dead?
No.
This all must be really bad.
Bro, we're going to be in here forever.
If the doll is not going to speed up, it's going to take forever.
Oh, my God.
This all sucks!
Blonde, they deleted the blonde girl that's fast.
Wait, they deleted her?
Why?
We won fast!
No, but the blonde boy isn't the fast one.
We won the fast one!
The blonde girl is the fast one.
Why would they delete the fastest?
Is it the same speed the entire round?
Or does it get faster?
It will get faster from round to round, but not during the round, I don't think.
Maybe if it's going to take too long, they're going to just speed it up manually.
So that, like, one step is like 20 blocks.
How many times does it have to hit you?
Like, a few times there, right?
Two or four.
Depending on which goal it is.
Don't you know?
The real RNG.
They made it fast now.
They're listening.
Oh, they're listening to us.
Shift, shift, shift.
He'd be really cool if, like, the admins give us extra help.
Hey, it would be really cool if they let you put more RNG in here.
If it says you're getting hunted, then...
It would be really funny.
If I'm getting hunted, I won't say a thing, guys.
All I'm saying.
If I get hunted, I'm not going to say anything.
I want to...
I'm going to say, I will help out the group.
Guys, it would be fun if they added more RNG.
Guys, don't you want to watch the underdog?
Main channel!
Don't you want to watch the underdog make it to the final round?
I am the underdog.
I should get more RNG.
It would be so funny.
Okay, tell me when I'm back on the main channel.
And I'm going to preach it.
I'm going to preach it if I make it to the main channel.
I thought he was the fireball one.
Okay.
What is this one, anyway?
Okay, I like how they increased the speed, but everybody is still alive.
So, what does this one do?
I think he's just super strong.
He's just super strong.
So, where is he?
Where is he?
He's 0.1.
If you say left, does that mean we run left?
If I say left, then that means we go right.
If you say left, we right.
Run the way Shata says.
If you see it on the right, yell left.
Yeah, whatever way gets called, run that way.
Why are we making it so complicated?
Why are we faking...
Guys, make sure that you're rounding corners instead of going close to them.
I swear, if this messes me up, if I die because of F5, it's on you guys.
Don't give me no shit.
We all know my weakness.
That's what they said they were going to do, but I didn't see a single blonde girl.
Going back aboard a boy.
I'm really like...
It's just not possible.
Where is the doll?
Plus one!
Increase the doll!
Increase the doll speed!
I think they should.
Give us some more talent.
Stay locked in.
There's still six of us in the night here.
I like that.
Spawn the doll next to us.
Do it.
It'll be so funny.
Slow it down.
What is happening?
Oh my god.
Can you make it reverse?
Wait.
If the doll is not locked in on anybody, will it even move?
Yeah, it just goes in random directions.
It always hunts.
It's always hunting?
Then why are they saying the doll is at the center?
Maybe it sees through walls.
They're speeding dolls up again?
Speed the doll up and spawn one right next to us.
Spawn one doll next to each group.
It'll be so funny.
If you want content,
spawn the doll next to each group.
And then, like, increase the speed.
Blood armor!
Toki is fine.
It'll be so funny.
And I'm gonna get eliminated first after seeing all the fun.
I'll spot you on top of our heads.
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm gonna hunt it over there.
We're gonna just throw it in the group.
Yeah, I did.
I did.
I did, I did, I did.
Oh, wait.
Somebody is hunting them.
Everybody is starting moving to them.
Don't go too far.
Oh, I'm locked in.
My brain is your brain now.
What is going on?
A great migration.
A great migration right now.
The penguin huddle.
Wait, one person is almost more scary.
No!
Why are they whispering to each other?
We can still hear you.
They might have gone into a hide hole.
No, if they go into a hide hole, it, like, highlights it on the map for us for a second.
Yeah, we can see it now.
We don't know where the dolls are.
We don't know.
Nobody's dead.
Nerd.
No, we don't know.
Nobody's dead.
That's the worst part.
Nice.
What the heck?
Come on.
Come on, this is a victory, bitch.
Guys.
Oh, no.
Andres.
Go for a walk, please.
Of course it was Andres.
Get over there, get over there.
What?
Go over there.
Come on, speed up the dogs.
Speed up the dogs.
Nobody has done it still, right?
No, nobody's died.
Everybody's still alive.
Second round is literally just chilling.
Like, the most anxious type of chilling.
None of the groups are moving.
We just saw them.
Just in the corner.
Not relaxed, but filled with anxiety.
Don't be in two spots.
Who wants to volunteer to run into the other group?
Oh my god.
That's so fast.
If you're happy and you know how to clap your hands, that's not a problem.
Goodbye.
I'm free.
Oh my god.
Where did the dog come from?
It actually came from nowhere.
No.
I jinxed myself.
I didn't realize they actually listened.
They
actually listened.
Okay, look.
I said it would be funny.
But I didn't.
They spotted next to me.
Oh my god.
It actually came out of nowhere.
Holy shit.
The karma was real.
It was so real.
They were...
Oh my god.
I can't...
No.
The one time I was like...
It would be so funny if they do all that.
I get hit.
I actually...
I actually got hit by that.
That's actually insane.
Oh my god.
I did not expect that at all.
I mean 63 out of 150.
I call that a win.
Alright.
Gumi needs to live.
So I'm really free.
Oh my god.
I don't have to...
Okay guys.
I'll explain to you about game 2.
Game 2 was so messed up.
Game 2...
Okay.
That doll was so messed up.
That doll was actually so fast.
Like I was so surprised how fast it was.
It literally came out of nowhere.
Nobody realized it was gonna come.
It actually came out of nowhere.
I'll explain the second game and why.
I was like... I hope to god I don't make it to the second game.
Because the second game was actually...
It was actually like...
It's not even RNG anymore.
So it's like Hunters and...
It's like Hunters versus Prey.
So it's sort of like Prod Hunt.
But there's no props.
And like Hunters...
Hunters has to get...
It's not a team game by the way.
It's not a team game unless you're a Prey.
The Prey is a team game.
Because like each Prey... Prey has to get 5 notes to survive.
If the Prey gets all 5 notes and survives...
The Hunters...
The Hunters with the lowest elimination will get eliminated.
And they have to do several rounds of that.
So like... But then there was like a lot of other stuff.
There were like a lot of other things in there too.
There were a lot of rules in there.
Individual rules.
I'm like simplifying this.
But it was so complicated.
So there was like...
It was like a more skilled game.
Because the third one...
was full on.
There was a parkour.
The third game was...
I also didn't want to live to the third game.
Because the third game was like...
There was parkour.
There was a maze.
This is all in one game.
There was a parkour.
Maze.
An escape room.
It's all individual.
And there's traps.
There's traps.
In every single objective.
But the thing is...
If you die from each of those...
From any of those areas...
You get reset.
Because your team can help you in a way.
There's like things there where you need a team...
Where you need a person to be there to help you.
So...
So like...
So like the escape room...
Your teammates can help you for the escape room.
But they can also choose to not help you as well.
Because it's all individual tasks you have to do in the escape room.
So like...
But if you die in any of them...
You get reset to the beginning.
Of the area.
So I was like...
Yeah...
I saw the maze part.
I saw the maze.
And there's like spike traps too.
Apparently.
There's like spike traps at the maze area and stuff like that.
And I was like...
Yeah...
I was just like...
No...
There's two mazes!
Okay...
I thought there was one maze.
It's parkour paintings maze.
And basically...
If you get caught by a ghost...
If you get caught by the ghost...
In that painting maze...
You are reset to the beginning of the maze.
So...
And then...
The third one...
Was a spike maze.
If you die by the spikes...
You get reset to the beginning of the maze.
And then...
If you went through all that mental torture...
You get to do the escape room.
So that's why...
I was like...
Oh my god...
Just take me here.
Oh thank god.
I was getting tortured by the dolls.
You know...
I took some minecraft pros down with me.
Rest in peace 5up.
It was funny though.
Not gonna lie.
You would have been in the next game.
But it was so funny.
I thought you died next to me.
Just for me...
Just for me to die first in the next round.
Also...
Guys...
I found out...
That on Friday...
Is the Summer Games Fest.
So I'm gonna be doing a watch along.
It might be...
I might just have one rest day.
Summer Games Fest watch along on Twitch.
At like 2pm.
It starts at 2pm right?
Or does it start at 3pm?
Whatever time it starts...
We're gonna do a watch along on the 7th.
So yeah...
I'll see you guys back on Twitch on the 7th.
I guess.
God that was so funny.
I can't believe.
The one time I got confident.
I actually got karma so hard.
Every time I had zero confidence.
And I didn't troll.
We were okay.
And then the moment where I spawned the doll right next to us.
It will be so funny.
And then they spawned the doll right next to me.
Oh my god.
It's actually...
Messed up.
Goomy wants me to watch Goomy's POV.
I'm watching her POV.
Why?
It was funny though.
It was pretty funny.
What do you mean she called me for not watching the corner?
What do you mean?
I should not be watching that corner.
There was a huge...
A huge pack next to us.
There was literally...
A horde.
Why was it me?
That had to watch it?
Why?
There were actual Minecraft players.
They should not depend on me.
To watch a corner.
That's so stupid.
Why would you depend on somebody that didn't even know what was going on?
That was trying to sabotage.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let me pull up my stream labels.
Because I want to thank everybody.
I want to say thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you for the tier 1.
Random vtuber 13.
Thank you for gifting a sub to 5.
Merlin and Crazy.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub.
I'm trying to look at the gifteds right now.
Where are the...
Where are the gifteds?
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Do I...
Guys, I'm sorry.
My thing doesn't sync.
Where are the gifted settings?
Donation.
Oh no.
Guys, I don't remember how to use my labels.
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
No, that's not what it is.
I just refreshed it.
Sorry, I'm trying to remember where the gifts are.
Wait, are there no gifts here?
Where are the gifts?
Professional streamers.
Anyway, thank you for all the gifts, guys.
Dragon, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Well, I get to start my rest now.
What a day, though.
Huge shoutout for Twitch.
For random vtuber.
Thank you for gifting a sub to Keck W.
I'm just going to say a huge shoutout for the invite.
I know I was, like, crying about it.
That I made it this far.
But, like, honestly, we had...
What a ride, though.
What an insane ride we had together.
That was actually crazy.
I don't think any of us expected, like, the game...
expected it to be like this.
Day 3 was actually crazy.
Oh my god.
But, yeah, huge shoutout.
Huge shoutout to, like, the invite and for going through this whole crazy event.
I lasted all the way to Day 4.
I mean, I'm proud of myself.
I beat so many pro Minecraft players.
And we made it so far.
So, yeah.
It was fun.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
It's finally over.
We have freedom now.
It's finally...
It's finally over.
We're all free.
We can now enjoy...
We can now enjoy resting.
I'm gonna go raid Gumi so you can check out the rest of the...
the rest of the journey if she's still alive.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cuz you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Alright, bonus ending.
I forgot to chill.
As always.
If you guys don't know, I stream on YouTube, so check me out there.
Anyone know whenever I stream on Twitch, check do exclamation point Twitter.
And follow me on Twitter.
Also, YouTube's reveal... YouTube's figure reveal.
I'm gonna tweet about it later.
The YouTube's figure.
Yeah.
What else?
If you wanna support me via other means, check out my merch.
Thank you, guys.
Forgot to chill.
Anyway, bye for real.